[Musica]
giorno al castello guardate un po che
bella visuale abbiamo sul cortile
interno del castello vi piace il mio
outfit mi sono vestita un po da non far
vedere già fatte devo ancora mettermi le
scarpe e ciabatte si è già fatto con le
calze che per mettere le scarpe
ora va in punizione dello sgabello reale
per aver indossato le ciabatte con le
carte e rimangono periodo watt ed allora
si possa qualcuno la vede vitale chiuse
quando va bene finita la tua punizione
per aver indossato le ciabatte con le
cause però devi metterti le scarpe a che
volevo mettere le scarpe hanno bussato
vogliono aprire no non posso perché è
solo in punizione stati libero da una
punizione da un no no adesso devo primo
a mettere le scarpe privo di andare
no io non voglio andare ad aprire è un
po inquietante quello porto non voglio
andare ad aprire dai tu uffa vado io
controlla prima chi è chi è
ma non c'è nessuno ma ho sentito uno
straniero è stato il vento o fantasma
anzi nessuno non c'è niente non hanno
lasciato niente non stanno bussando alla
porta adesso la feritoia che abbiamo
aperto ieri notte
forse qualcuno si è arrabbiato perché
l'abbiamo aperta senza permesso forse il
resto è arrabbiato o il proprietario di
questo cartello gli abitanti di questo
castello che ancora non abbiamo visto
vediamo se c'è qualcosa ma troviamo
questa è una ragnatela gigante giallo
aspetta c'è qualcosa che porta a un'idea
20 to lavano così impossibile che cadrai
da qua
prendi con quella cosa che c'è lì
effettivamente c'è qualcosa piano piano
che cos'è by roberto di una lettera e il
sigillo del re il sigillo del lupo sì
c'è scritto una lettera forse vuole
darci il benvenuto
proviamo ad aprirla perché come sali
nella feritoia ho un'idea che dopo
usciamo fuori e guardiamo questa
feritoia da fuori perché magari
scopriamo dove abita e dove realmente in
rete c'è scritto benvenuti nel mio
castello finché sarete i miei ospiti
dovrete superare varie prove la prima
prova è esplorare il castello e scoprire
i suoi segreti
riuscirete a trovare il cavaliere fate
attenzione a non disturbare gli abitanti
centenari del castello a presto e
sopravviverete sopravvivere amiamo ma
anche senso abitanti centenari ci sono
forze tanti vecchietti e penso che
intenda qualcos'altro ma comunque è
meglio che iniziamo la prova subito
prima che ci mandi qualche altra lettera
o qualcos'altro
attraverso la feritoia c'è uno stupido
ed esploriamo il castello si prima
mentre scarpe vero perché con le
ciabatte un po più difficile
questo è il terrazzo che avete visto
ieri al buio evitatelo sul ponte
levatoio
[Musica]
guardarlo sembra faccia stradale sarà
forse uno degli indizi uno degli
abitanti guarda un po inquietante triste
vediamo quante facce in pietra o cose
strane riusciamo a trovare anche voi
state attenti e scrivete nei commenti
tutte le facce o cose strane che vedete
ora nel castello ok andiamo
questo è il cortile del castello curate
capello
parla a bassa voce perché il re ha detto
di non disturbare gli abitanti del
castello che potrebbero arrabbiarsi
[Musica]
guarda qui c'è un indizio
che cos'è sono due uomini uno con un
fungo e 11 in blocco la penso che un
fungo
ecco i giardini del castello vediamo
quante facce o creature nella pietra
riusciamo a trovare guardate inquietante
questo che cos'è la secondo tempo un
drago sembra un gatto gargoyle e si di
notte questi priorità è stupendo
guardate che io
[Musica]
vita sì ma è solo una statua però se si
trasformasse anche lui forse erano i
proprietari del castello c'è questo
oppure sono dei parenti del re lo
scopriremo molto presto spero che
cos'era poterlo mare per uno sparo miss
ed è un po che bel panorama
la vita penso di aver scoperto qualcosa
che cosa c'è qualcosa di tutte un ragno
il taglio è solo una statua
[Musica]
dove sta scappando evitare seguente
patate mostro marino le servivano è
ancora pensando a mangiare questi sono i
giardini del castello curati che per lì
ci sono tantissime volte si sono
bellissimi
[Musica]
guardate abbiamo trovato uno strano
cerchio di panchine li guardate magari a
queste erano solo le panchine delle
streghe questo è il circolo delle
streghe cercherò il circolo g siamo
seduti qua nelle banchine delle streghe
si è vitale ha notato qualcosa di strano
[Musica]
anche qui inquietanti dobbiamo riuscire
a trovare tutte le creature sculture
opposizioni che troviamo perché porta
quello che intendeva il re come
aumentando i centenari e spero che non
prendano vita e serrare la vera sformati
in pietra perché perché gli umani li ha
trasformati in in statue e li abbiamo
visti qua sotto
gli animali con gli artigli la
trasformati in panchina
poveri che si trasformerà in stato anche
a noi allora forse è meglio scappare via
subito da questo castello quando noi
dovremmo scappare via subito
lasciate un mi piace qui sotto per
portarci fortuna io però prima di
scappare io do castelo andremo a
mangiare un attimino qualcosa per me i
temi come sono già non possiamo
viaggiare lo stomaco vuoto mi sono
andati continuiamo a cercare le creature
è meglio che le individuiamo tutti ma
c'è qualcosa dobbiamo vedere
mi sono punta o no c'è qualcosa qua
guarda cos'è un pozzo
effettivamente ci sono dei disegni la
sua che cosa c'è disegnato lì sopra non
c'è è un uccello tipo con angelini
tedesco e molto misterioso questo pozzo
perché è stato nascosto qua
guardiamo meglio cosa c'e raffigurato
guarda riesce a vedere e fanno due leoni
per questo è un bottone girato e
riguardo nascosto bening esecuzione
pensa che stia semplicemente un patto da
pioli non un bottone un altro essere
umano trasformato in pietra guarda
ok abbiamo esplorato quasi tutti i
giardini del castello che hanno varie
statue
quali strani ora cerchiamo la feritoia
che nella nostra stanza dove il
passaggio così scopriamo il rene da dove
ho messo la lettera andiamo verso così
sono quattro feritoie e una di queste
allora secondo me la feritoia giusta
festa questa qui come file fa perché
quella è perché è l'unica che sta
all'altezza della mia stanza mi ha fatto
il re a salire per la sola guarda tra
l'altro la sopra c'è la statua di pietra
di un falco
diamo faccia qualche pasta già fa metro
d'acqua è impossibile arrampicarti
arrivare la giunta di deve avere
utilizzato qualche passaggio segreto
c'è una finestra con delle sbarre
forse sono le segrete del castello
meglio allontanarsi
[Musica]
comunque a me non sembra un posto
stregato o malefico anzi mi sembra un
posto fiabesco vorrei vivere qua
aspetta un attimo che cosa c'è lì ho
visto qualcosa su quel balcone dove non
vedo niente che cosa hai visto lo so ho
visto un'ombra sembrava come se ci fosse
una specie di fantasma affacciato al
balcone ma che dici fantasmi non
esistono
e poi perché dovrebbe affacciarsi al
balcone forse per spiegarci per bene
eppure ti giuro che ho visto qualcosa là
sopra sembrava proprio un fantasma si
sta anche alzando il vento quindi io
come il presentimento che noi non siamo
ben graditi qua forse è meglio scappare
secondo me ti sta venendo un po di paura
arabe torniamo in camera così ti passa
la paura non c'è nessun fantasma qua
sono solo leggende quelle dei fantasmi
nei castelli dai andiamo
[Musica]